[Music]
okay I have this Sirius XM show and
we've been doing it for 14 years now and
it's funny because it's a radio show but
now when I get guests on they all think
it's a podcast right like in the last
year that that shift is happening that's
definitely a seismic shift it would have
any other way around a podcast it's on
the radio you should bump it to a
podcast it feels like that's more
prestigious now right say it's a podcast
yes even doing that for a long time how
often do you do that once well used to
be once a week now it's about once every
two weeks right it's cool do you enjoy
that that's fun I've managed to get a
really good guest list so it's been
that's been helpful super cool just one
of eight billion things that you're up
to yeah but but that one has really been
fun because I get to you know meet
people that I've always looked up to or
right it should been interested in yeah
case in point right here that's a
greatest gift of this thing is I get to
convince people like you to come and
talk to me so I really appreciate it
sure I think that the first thing I want
to kind of dig into with you is just
being 50 you know I'm 51 we're about the
same age I'm an athlete very different
kind of athlete but I'm really
interested in kind of how you think
about what it means to be 50 and how
that affects or doesn't affect like what
you do in your sport how you think about
your sport kind of your daily routines
what you can and can't do and and the
boundaries that you either place or
don't place on yourself well I never put
ultimatums out there in terms of if I
reach this age I can't do this anymore
so I feel like I was I knew this was
coming and I knew it was a big milestone
and I was trying to ignore it but as it
came and people started to put so much
attention all other people can't ignore
it pretty much I was it was other people
that convinced me like you really are
old hey I mean in terms of for what I do
and I'm proud of that you know and for
sure I am shifting my style and and I do
you know I don't participate in so many
things I don't do so many risky
maneuvers or terrains that I used to
but I'm still found a way to do what I
do and enjoy it and be progressive at it
so I feel like I've sort of been not
forced to but but have chosen to change
my style up so that I can continue to do
it at this age right um and it
definitely is what keeps me fit I don't
have a workout routine you know I don't
I don't do yoga and stuff as I know I
probably should yeah I probably will
eventually but at this point yeah yeah
another thing I'm forced into yeah but
by other people but I but it really it's
just been more about figuring out how to
do this into into this age right this
decade
well what's amazing is you know when I
don't know what your experience is but
when I was a kid when I was 14 15 years
old the idea that somebody would be
athletic in their 50s was insane like oh
well with skateboarding when I was a kid
you couldn't skate into your 20s like it
just wasn't an option because there was
no career to be had for it and it was
considered this kid activity so if you
were skating past you know high school
it was like what's wrong with you right
look he's in mattel syndrome like what
you've got to grow up Peter Pan but even
even beyond skating in any sport that
anybody would even graduating remotely
athletic into their 50s would would have
been a radical concept right yeah to be
rare specimen of some guy that like
random marathon that's amazing he ran a
marathon right um but but that I guess
just with our knowledge of of health and
of of of life and and what works I feel
like that that's what's changed
everything
yeah in terms of the the general society
and the general acceptance of being fit
yeah you know and and being being active
at this age is what keeps you healthy of
course right
yeah there's definitely all these
advances in nutrition and training
techniques and you know the technology
of whatever sport you find yourself in
but I just feel like there's a there's a
there's a we're in a culture that allows
us to explore this later in life that
wasn't exactly that permissive
back then and so you're seeing older
athletes pushing the boundaries and
doing amazing things and there are
various disciplines like across the
board and I think that's super cool yeah
I'm glad to be part of it I feel like
I'm somewhat of a litmus test for how
far you can take it mm-hmm
there's plenty of people that are
skating into their 50s and whatnot but I
feel like I'm the one that's still out
there sort of in public doing it and
trying to prove that you can still be
relevant you're that you're the canary
in the coal mine I think that's the
distinguishing factor like being
relevant at the highest level in your
sport versus just remaining active my
latest obsession is this woman who is my
oldest podcast fan she's 96 and she went
plant-based a year ago and now she's on
Instagram she's got like 13,000
followers laughs Graham and she posts
like her daily workout routines and like
what she's eating and stuff like that
and she has this following and it's like
she's doing working out with bands and
all this kind of stuff with a trainer
and I just find out to be so inspiring
let's may 1960 she's coming up on a
hundred right yeah Anna's um well that's
a far cry from my mom is my mom is 94
but she has dementia so means yeah she's
not an Instagram I'll tell you that yeah
well that that kind of brings up another
issue I instead of wrapping my head
around you know how I wanted to approach
this today and what I wanted to talk to
you about I reached out to our mutual
friend Steve oh oh yeah and I was like
because I don't know anything about
skateboarding I was like Steve like
Tony's coming on what should we talk
about and he told me that he had a super
fascinating conversation with you about
CTE or you know TBI like the the sort of
impact of hmm persistent can concussions
on brain health and the like and he told
he told me that that you took some tests
at some point that allowed you to figure
out whether you were more prone to you
know sort of be susceptible to injuries
like yeah well it was by suggestion of
my wife I was trying to be proactive
because obviously this this problem is
pervasive and it's not just about ball
sports any sport where you can suffer
concussions and so
I had a pretty intense blood test and
what I learned is that I don't have the
gene that makes you more susceptible to
Alzheimer's mm-hmm and because of that
and the night and then I went sort of
down this rabbit hole of information and
I found an expert who actually wrote a
thesis in San Diego and she's she's a
neurologist and she said that if you
don't have that gene that allows your
brain to heal from concussions if you do
have that gene generally you won't heal
from concussions and that is the key to
CTE is the idea you're getting multiple
concussions you have this gene that
doesn't allow your brain to feel right
right and I know I sound like some
wannabe expert here but this is exactly
how she explained it to me
and she said because I have I don't have
this gene I am able to heal my brain
from concussions and that's not to say
that it wouldn't have some effect on me
later on because I've definitely had
concussions within a short time period
one after the other which is you know
the recipe for disaster but it
definitely made me more aware and
definitely more proactive and trying to
stay safer and realizing mild
concussions are can be just as traumatic
in a lot of ways especially if they're
in repression yeah and so then after
that I actually went had a cognitive
test that I will continue to take every
six months to a year to make sure I'm
not deteriorating so and even I guess
the irony there is if you do take those
tests and you are deteriorating there's
not a lot you can do about it yeah yeah
that's right I mean Alzheimer's is I
mean you're experiencing it firsthand
devastating and and I've had specialists
on this show who who are doctors in that
field and they're having some pretty
remarkable results through diet and
lifestyle but in terms of like a medical
protocol to reverse it or prevent it
they're really baffled still right yeah
and I and I know all that going into it
and and it's not gonna change what I do
it just it just changes my approach a
little bit it's and it's not even that
it may
me more cautious it just makes me more
aware and hypersensitive to any sort of
head injury even if it's the slightest
yeah if you had tested for that gene and
you found out that you had it put that
it was a question I think I would I
think it would I think it would at least
give me pause and also make me research
better protection but at this point I
ride for a helmet company that I firmly
believe in and I feel like that's the
safest I can be on my skateboard with
the Salman on Triple Eight
when did the helmets come in well I mean
it's it's they haven't really come in
it's hard to explain um when I was when
I was young I skated in skate parks like
designated you know in the late 70s
uh-huh
skid pads were mandatory you couldn't
enter the park without full full pads
even sometimes with wrist guards so for
from my experience that's just what how
it was you had to our paths and so pads
B were just the norm it wasn't until the
the sort of shift of Street skating in
in the skateboarding culture that pads
became not cool or considered useless
because kids are just skating down the
street going down stairs and one like
that and then now there's a sort of
blend because if you're skating the
bigger stuff the bigger ramps the bigger
parks your pads are gonna save your life
your helmet is for sure and in knee pads
for the most part because that's the
only way to get out of being way up in
the air safely but but there's another
mindset that is like well we we just do
this on our own terms
and we don't wear pads and there's a
masais that there's a battle between
those those camps of thinking but it's
going to come to a head when
skateboarding anything enters the
Olympics right and there's a little sort
of mix of both styles of skating and I
think some people will be wearing pads
and some won't
and I don't know how that's gonna play
out you
it's a cultural thing right I mean
you're talking about a sport that is
super unique and distinct from any other
sport other than perhaps surfing where
it's this strange mashup of a true sport
physical activity but also lifestyle
culture and and really arts absolutely
and with that comes this ethos right
that sort of emanates from punk rock and
being counterculture and you know again
yeah man and for me I'm torn in that
sense because I do believe in the DIY
sense of skating and and the the
counterculture that it is and it always
was but at the same time I want people
to live I want them to I want them to
survive another day and I don't want to
encourage kids to do something that
truly could destroy their lives yeah
well I saw that you tweeted out a couple
times this fundraiser I think is
actually happening today in in Minnesota
for Dave Mehra's yes it's Gabe Marin
Kevin Robinson
and Kevin Robinson right so so I never
knew Dave personally but when he got
into triathlon in a big way like we
became internet buddies and he did the
race across America with some friends of
mine so we were sort of acquainted in
that way and and it was just such a
shock and and a tragedy when he passed
in the way that he did I mean is there
do we know if concussions or head
injuries had any sort of impact and I I
don't have any definitive information on
that I heard that he might have shown
signs of CTE but I don't want to spread
rumors I don't really don't have direct
knowledge of it but it seems in terms of
what we know about it now and and the
kind of injuries Dave endured
it's very possible yes right yes so same
with Kevin Robinson I'm gonna Ken
Robinson he has some of the heaviest
concussions I've ever seen in person
mm-hmm you know the kind of stuff that
he did where he fought he's he was out
right and and affected for long periods
of time and so that could have been
played into that as well right well on
the subject
the Olympics I mean this is this is huge
this is pretty exciting 2020
skateboarding making its debut were you
involved behind the scenes and making
this happen I would assume is his decade
yeah I mean I was I was definitely an
advocate for it I wasn't I wasn't
championing I wasn't like you know
holding holding any any sort of big
pushes but but I do want it to if it's
going to happen I wanted to see it
happen with integrity and I feel like I
at least have a voice and and some
influence on that right so I joined up
with the ISF international skateboard
Federation which is now become world
skate and they are the ones who are sort
of ushering it in and and showing the
IOC how to delicately handle the world
of skateboarding counterculture in a way
that is presentable right it doesn't
mean it's gonna change how we do it
doesn't mean it's gonna change the
format of competition but definitely a
way to make the the sort of non skating
public understand what it is right well
they've been able to do it with
snowboarding but you have snowboarding
went through I don't you know if you
don't remember it when when somebody was
in Nagano I was treated like the right
it was treated like the dark horse of
the of the games because people like
were like look at these kids you know
they're punks and what the one guy
tested positive for weed because he
contact higher stomaching and but but
also but but that was that was the whole
vibe right you know that's people came
away from and it was like they because
of how the mainstream media was treating
it and they didn't realize that that's
what the kids are watching I think the
kids don't want to watch ice skating
anymore
you know or or anymore speed skating
like I I appreciate all those sports but
how many swimming events do we need yeah
well when you say making sure that it's
introduced with integrity what I'm
saying is what I was what I was saying
is that is the snowboarding went through
this this growing pain because that that
happened and then four years later NBC
figured it out well you need a champion
you need somebody that everybody
the champion I think is they just
realized that the youth was into these
kind of sports for sure Shaun White was
a big part of that but what I'm saying
is four years later they realized that
that the only way they're gonna get a
youthful audience is is by highlighting
this youthful sport and which they did
obviously in Shaun was the breakaway
star from that but but I feel like they
wised up and I think that skateboarding
won't have to go through that phase
because skipping is already more popular
than most Olympics prides your summer
games right um so I feel optimistic
about that uh-huh and there's a lot of
pushback from the skate community you
know we don't need this all corporate
and this is mainstream and sanitized and
whatnot but the you know this is not the
first time skateboarding has been a
competitive sport no no of course not I
started competing I was ten years old
well it's it's kind of the crowning
achievement or culmination of your
legacy which is in my mind at least like
assuring in this thing that you love
into mainstream acceptance and embrace I
mean there's nothing more like having it
in the Olympics is kind of like the
ultimate in suddenly it being like
ubiquitous that's true but but there I I
have I am a little torn because I feel
that way in one in one sense but in the
other sense I feel like we don't need
the Olympics validation to know that
we're legitimate to know that we are the
skateboarding is popular it just is and
so there's a part of me that's that
things that they need us more than we
need them that's probably true
um and but at the same time the silver
lining is that skateboarding will reach
a new audience in terms of other
countries other cultures where it's
never been seen or or even tested mm-hmm
yeah it'll be interesting to see the the
sort of down wave impact of that on kids
like the kids you just met you know
before here like does just seeing it in
the Olympics inspire more kids to want
to get into it or does that cut across
what makes it appealing to them which is
that it's not part of that world and
it's their own thing
I think that's twofold I think for one
it'll it'll encourage some kids to get
into it have never
seen him before in the other part of
that is that it will encourage kids to
get into it because they want to be a
champion and that was never the
motivation in my generation that's
becoming more of the mindset not not
across the board but in a lot of ways
there are kids that they get in skating
because they know you can be rich and
famous as a skater but also now you can
be an Olympian and and sometimes that is
the directive but that that's just how
that's just with any sport well going
back to like the beginning of your
career I mean being rich and famous
obviously was never part of the mindset
wasn't what just was it never happened
it wasn't an option yeah I mean but at
the same time you were you were kind of
on the younger end of that Bones Brigade
kind of generation of people and and my
impression is that you came in with a
little bit of a different mindset a
competitive mindset and you know you
didn't necessarily come from this you
know you weren't gonna drug grow
dreadlocks and and be a super punk
rocker like you were approaching it from
a more methodical kind of champion
mindset I it wasn't even to be champion
it was just it was just more to prove
myself to be validated the only way you
could be recognized when I when I was
started skating was to compete you were
only ever rated on your your competition
rankings it no one was shooting video
throwing big stunts for video you know
or or even you wouldn't get coverage the
magazine unless you competed so that was
the only way that I could get any sort
of recognition and and that was so so my
drive was to get better competition to
get more well-rounded as a skater and to
do that and it was sort of only after
ten years of competition I realized
there might be other avenues and other
ways to be a pro skater other than just
competing was it really ten years in
because I weren't you weren't you
beginning to try these tricks and do
things that were kind of different from
the traditional competition framework
yeah I was I think it was so I started
competing in 1979-1980
and around 1989 is
when the era of skate videos came into
play and I think that was when the shift
started happening and when I realized
that I was able to document these these
really difficult moves that I wouldn't
be doing in competition because they're
you know they take too many tries to
actually make one but I felt like there
was this new outlet and this new mindset
in terms of how people are being
progressive and so that was that was
what I chose to focus on for the most
part but but I did still compete because
you had to keep your you had to keep
that foot in the door right because that
still was the way to be rated but at the
time the emphasis was on the the
competition side and you were like there
was a new wave of people doing what you
were doing but it was still kind of an
outlier thing that wasn't exactly like
you know hey what are you doing over
there like that you're not supposed to
do that come back over here yeah I think
it really wasn't until the popularity
sort of fell out of favor in the early
90s is when there was a big shake-up in
terms of skate style and skate culture
because then all the skate parks closed
for the most part and the only people
who skated were doing it in places where
they weren't allowed to do it which
meant Street skating and suddenly people
started to realize that the urban
landscape could be a skate park right is
that when pool skating came in that's no
I'm saying that's when pool skating came
out okay so like in early 90s is when
all the parts were closing up right post
getting started in in the late 70s
uh-huh and then skate parks in the 80s
opened to emulate backyard pools so all
the skate parks that were the ones that
I'm speaking of that we're closing were
ones that actually had pools in them but
were made for skateboard right I see so
then when when the those sort of dried
up in the in the late 80s and early 90s
kids took to the streets and and sort of
created their own way to use the
cityscape mm-hmm as a skate park which
meant stairs handrails benches all that
kind of stuff
and then they were marked as absolute
outcasts and rebels because they were
doing it in public
and and you know really annoying the
pedestrians yeah so there was no the
competition framework went away the
competitions were sold there why did it
all dry up in 91 or whatever well it was
because it was a few different reasons
because skating was cyclical it was
always like it had come into favor in
the late 70s fell out of favor in the
early 80s came back into favor in the
late 80s and then fell out again so that
that was sort of it was something we
were in denial of but it was happening
and kept happening and also in the late
eighties liability it was impossible
liability liability insurance for skate
parks all the skate parks were private
and they couldn't afford the insurance
and the way that the liability laws were
for public spaces did not favor a sport
like skateboarding mm-hmm
so public skate park couldn't exist hmm
and in nineteen I'm gonna have the year
wrong here but I want to say it's it was
somewhere around 1997 six or seven the
liability laws changed in the US where
skateboarding was added to the hazardous
activities list and if you participate
in skateboarding you you assume your own
liability in the same way that you would
rock climbing you're skiing right and
that's when everything changed and
people were allowed to have a public
space a public skate park without being
monitored and in kids were at their own
risk that's so interesting I had no idea
that it was really a change in the law
that was it yeah
and there were there was there was a law
group that was fighting yeah I'm sure
right yeah Wow
so all right so just working our way
through your career up to this point I
mean you go pro at 14 you start making
all this money you buy a house when
you're still in high school like you're
doing great like this whole career is is
opening up in front of you you're the
new rising star in the sport then 91 it
kind of all goes away right and yeah and
you're faced with this choice go get a
real job or like kind of you know join
mainstream society and I I take it a lot
of
pro skaters at that time that's what
they did there was no other choice and
you make this decision to like double
down you take a second mortgage out on
your house and you go all-in at a time
when nobody everybody thought
skateboarding was gone for good so walk
me through like how and why you make
that decision because that's really the
pivotal moment that ya created
everything uh well I I I saw obviously I
saw skate brains popularity waning but
also the the company I was with was sort
of considered the dinosaur company
because all these little companies
started coming in and making a splash
and doing things very rebellious and I
you know and as as unique of a culture
of skateboarding is our our
powell-peralta was considered like the
big corporate entity it was like it was
like the nitrite
even though skippering was a small
industry and so i decided i wanted to do
my own company because i wanted to sort
of have my own aesthetics and have my
own direction but stay in the industry
and and i thought that i was 24 at the
time i thought that my career as a
skater was ending because i was still a
vert skater bird skating was done was
done and it was all about Street and I
figured if I could get a good group of
street skaters together you know ones
that that I recognize and make my own
team I could at least get by right that
was the goal the goal was was to get by
just because I loved skating so much I
wanted to be in the industry I wanted to
have control of a brand and that was it
and and we were on a skeleton crew we
were I was doing all the marketing all
the ads the team stuff the tours you
know I was doing but not the
skateboarding I was skating - you were
that's I guess that's the funny thing is
I was always skating but only because I
just enjoyed it I wasn't skating to be a
team rider so to speak I was just
skating because I couldn't stop yeah and
then but but I guess that the the
the the main the tipping point for us in
terms of of scape of birdhouse and and
and us being successful was sometime
around then and we're on 1990 for a
couple years in the other guys on the
team said you're you're much more
effective as a team writer and being out
there skating than you are as a guy
working on up the donut ads right yeah
editing videos yeah and that's that sort
of held true throughout your career like
and do you feel that that is still wise
advice for you at 50 that you still need
to be on the board and out front and and
and as much the ambassador as you are
the you know sort of leading force
behind Tony Hawk Inc um yeah but but I
have a great I have a really good group
of people that I trust I trust their
aesthetics and their values and and so I
have a team in place that I know the
quality will always be there and yeah
sure I want to walk the walk you know I
want I want to be I want to be relevant
I want to still be skating but at the
same time I have evolved enough that I
understand marketing and I understand
videos much more than I did when we were
starting and and you know if it was kind
of crushing to hear the team go your ads
kind of suck well back then I mean what
was but we didn't like we couldn't
afford to hire someone to do that so I
was going about to learn like I'd
learned how to express in Photoshop and
and do all those things because we
couldn't afford to have anyone do it but
at the time also it was this was a brand
new world there was no like here's how
you do it to launch your skate Brad I
mean yeah there were no there was
Peralta belly so this is when videos
coming in and it becomes all about you
know creating like an aesthetic and a
culture as much yeah there was not a
template yeah and we were relying on and
it wasn't like our products were
reinventing the wheel we were getting
our stuff made we're the coolest but but
it had to be cool so we had at least we
we we got a very iconic aesthetic going
through one of our team writers that was
an artist and I collected what I thought
was the best team
at the time and that's what carried us
through right and and back then I mean
who did you have mentors with stacy
peralta stacy peralta was definitely one
of my biggest inspirations in fact you
know he was the one who because I had to
come to him to tell him that I quit
early his team yeah and as as much as he
was upset by it he said look I can't I
can't tell you not to do this this is
what I did because he was a gene s team
writer and he left us to start
powell-peralta
and he's like I can't there's no way I
could discourage you from from going and
chasing this dream because that's
exactly what I did right and did he was
he helpful to you with early business
and like your business at 24 as much as
he could but but you know you're
competing again this could encourage
right right so was there a moment where
you felt like okay it's tipping and it's
starting to work I mean these are lean
times you know you've talked a lot about
like the $5 a day Taco Bell you know a
style that you were on the mortgage on
the house I'm sure everyone was telling
you you know you're crazy what are you
doing yeah well and especially just you
know I just had my first child
and bro irresponsible in there but but
again I was for the most part I was the
main caretaker of him so when I would go
travel and so if you just come with me
mm-hmm
by default but definitely we we had to
scale back on so many expenses and end
at birdhouse My partner and I a pair
will endure we kept taking pay cuts and
we kept you know doing the same with the
riders and it was it was becoming very
the the outlook was bleak but we we hung
in there to make it work right I think a
lot of people you know sort of want to
know well how do you know why did you
make this choice and why didn't you just
do what everyone else was doing but like
from what I gather from you it's it
wasn't really a choice like this is you
were gonna do this this skating was your
life you were all in from the get-go
yeah I there were I would say somewhere
after the first three years of of us
being in business practice is when we
had
heavy discussions about closing shop
right because we just weren't the
profits were not justifying the expenses
and the expenses were very smitten slim
yeah
and I started do I had some video
editing equipment and so I started
editing videos for other skate companies
and even other entities because I at
least knew how to put stuff together and
I could do it cheaply uh-huh but it was
I would say around 96 97 is when things
started really turning around right and
to the point where it got bigger than we
had anticipated and and we were we were
thankful cuz we were about to shut it
down right and you were perfectly
positioned because you'd been doing it
for so long you'd established
credibility in this space yeah that when
the law changed and then that went to
the ex-king X Games from 95 right it was
it was probably the second year of X
Games is when my well also just my name
recognition was out there because I had
I had had that through the 80s and then
it was a new generation and it was
mostly parents that were seeing this and
their kids were excited because they'd
never seen skateboarding on TV and then
their kids were like oh who's this guy
Tony Hawk and then their parents are
like oh I know Tony Hawk from you know
yeah and so I luckily I sort of survived
two generations of skating like that and
and that helped quite a bit and because
of that people were interested in bird
house uh-huh
and then fast forward to 1999 is when
our video video game got released right
and I had included obviously all of our
brands in it because I was trying to get
the exposure for it right but I had no I
you know we had no idea that we're gonna
create a whole new genre of video games
through doing that no I mean it's the
confluence of all of these things some
of which you had control over and many
of which you didn't that all came
together and almost this divine timing
to conspire to you know create what has
transpired but during those you know
lean times did you hold on to this
vision that it would become this big
thing or was that as a surprise it was
surprise to me I was just trying to I
was just trying to make a living you
know
I was not trying to get exponentially
rich ever it was just more I wanted to
keep skating I wanted to enjoy what I
was doing and if I could provide her
family by doing so that was good enough
right right and I still feel like so
right yeah everything else like all the
all the money and famous it's all gravy
and it's all obviously fun but at the
bottom line is I want to make sure that
my kids are provided for and that I'm
there for them mm-hmm but the driving
force beneath it is just your love for
this right like it's not it was never
about sure yeah yeah like all that all
the stuff that I've been doing
especially its skating wise these days
I'm not I'm not doing it because I'm
hoping that I'm you know hanging on to
that thread of Fame I'm doing it because
I really love it and I'm happy that
people are interested in it but I'm just
doing because I I would be doing it
anyway yeah like all the stuff that I'm
doing especially for skating and
appearances that I get paid ridiculous
amounts of money for I would do for free
yeah well it's such a blessing and a
rare thing for somebody to know very
young not only what they're good at but
what they love and to carry that through
their whole life but for a lot of people
you know people who are lucky enough to
find something that they love when
they're young the sort of you know
attrition of life wears that down and
they end up becoming something else
yeah be able to hold on to that I think
is is you know maybe that's your your
greatest talent of all of this maybe
yeah I think my just my stubbornness
yeah yeah because I think people seem to
ask you a lot like you know how do you
become the successful businessperson and
you know all that it's like you might my
path is not one that I can really say
one can emulate it you know and you know
it's the one a million that you get to
do it on this level absolutely right and
something that was never considered
legitimate but but but there are lessons
there in terms of perseverance and
following your passion and and quality
control that I feel like I can convey it
to other people and and fundamentally a
very healthy relationship with failure
which is inevitable if you're a skater
yeah from from the get-go your your
meeting failure on a daily
yes in a very physical and painful way
right and if you can't develop a
relationship a healthy relationship with
what it means to fall on your face not
only are you not going to make it as a
skater you're unlikely to you know
persevere and whatever else it is that
you're pursuing in your life yeah
absolutely and and that that carries
through even to business decisions where
I'm not really afraid to take risks is
right
I you know I know that's what it takes
to succeed yeah I think I heard you say
somewhere that there's a defining moment
in every skaters life and and and that's
what they do in the wake of their first
you know really gnarly crash I think so
they a lot of people try skating and the
first time they get hurt that's the
moment where they say oh I'm not doing
it ever again and the ones that that
persevere because they learn from that
mistake or because they're just driven
that's the moment where you know that
that you could make it right and so did
you have that did you have like a super
intense I did yeah when the first time I
got really hurt I got a concussion
because my helmet was terrible and I
knocked my front teeth out and I woke up
I woke up in the ambulance basically is
when I really became loosened and I knew
exactly what I had done how I fell what
I did wrong and my first thought was oh
like you know I gotta learn to figure
that out do it better right it wasn't
like I can't believe I did that I'm
gonna die I'm never skiing what am I
doing with very much like oh I can't
wait to get back out there and learn
that trick because now I know how to do
it right right what do you think are the
other big things that skating taught you
that serve you well in your business and
personal life um I think just that you
don't always have to follow the the
tried-and-true path that um it's not all
about doing it by the book so to speak
and it's about finding your own way and
and and making making it your own and
also
using not using but but taking cues from
from other successes and expanding on
them in terms of like quite literally
tricks like you take a track and you're
like well maybe this could be done a
little bit differently or or with an
extra spin or with a different flare and
the collective evolution of skating I
think is something that could be taken
to all kinds of different parts of life
or or businesses even so what would be
an example of that um I think that just
in terms of like scientific progress if
more groups were sharing their successes
and and there was more collective energy
to whatever to medicines to health but
everyone is so isolated in what they're
doing and so focused on their own
successes that it's almost like
everyone's working against each other
right like in a zero-sum game exactly
oliday yeah and skateboarding has never
been like that because it's just an open
architecture yeah
and as it remained true to that to this
yeah I guess in terms of competition
maybe some people try to keep it a
little close to the heart where if
they're learning something new or they
got a new thing they're not gonna unveil
it until right the big competition and
stakes are high now so that's
understandable
so let's go back to 9999 is when you do
you do this 900 right and you're 43 at
the time uh 31 oh you're 31 the first
time that's right okay you did it again
at 43 and 40-48 yeah I've done it since
the first time dozens of times so it
wasn't like every year was a certain
milestone but I'd like a stage or
whatever where there's a lot of people
there uh yeah that too but but when I
was 48 I hadn't tried it in about five
years so that was I felt like that was a
little more monumental right but yeah
it's still hard how many people have
done it now since you that's a good
question I want to say about ten or
eleven not really so still only a few
people right yeah but
at the same time it's just not it's not
the focus of skaters in terms of some
kid growing up skating the park or
skiing the street they don't care about
900 you know they care about a kickflip
frontside hurricane like that and that's
what their that's what their opus is
right but for for ramp skating it's
definitely a milestone but but even so a
couple kids have done 10 80s now Wow you
know because the ramps have gotten
bigger and and you learn to spin at an
earlier age and so that's the next
progression yeah got it but when this
happens for the first time in 99 I mean
that's another kind of milestone not
just in your life but in the kind of
Canon of skating right when this happens
because the mainstream culture took
notice of it yeah that was kind of
unprecedented yeah for sure it changed a
lot of things in my life and in terms of
recognition and opportunities it was
strange to me though because it was a
trick that I had been trying for 10
years on and off and I had learned 720's
14 years prior to that on a backyard
ramp in outside of Stockholm Sweden with
three people watching me and you know a
couple of claps and that was it it was
just wasn't a in the skate world it was
a milestone but it wasn't this
monumental achievement I mean it was
something I was proud of yeah sure yeah
and then to have so much attention on
the this next 180 spin 14 years later
was really strange to me because it was
like why didn't why do you care now well
what has changed so drastically and
obviously there there plenty of obvious
answers to that but it was really
strange to me where it was suddenly I
was getting stopped in airports by
people who had nothing new was skating
or like 900 bro yeah yeah but well the
YouTube video version of it has like 12
million views on it I think or something
yeah I mean it's still it I'm hugely
proud of it but like I said it was it
was a it was a strange shift for me and
and you know the the the perfect storm
timing of that was that we had been
working on a video game for two years up
to that point and it was about to be
released and so
that was this extra bonus of all that
yeah well I mean you couldn't have you
know with all your marketing expertise
you could not have connected to better I
simply couldn't play this thing yeah and
that video game had been in development
for like two years right leading up to
yeah and then when it was released it
was an it was like a quantum leap
forward in terms of what video games
could do and it just the timing was
amazing and it just exploded right yeah
change your life it changed my life
absolutely yeah and changed my
opportunities and and when I did that
you know 99 was already I was
considering that to be my last year of
competition just because I had been
competing for twenty years at that point
and to have that happen it was like well
that that's the obvious out I am NOT
high note I'm not gonna compete anymore
and then when the video game got
released suddenly I had all these
opportunities to do things outside a
competition that I had some that I had
dreamed of some that I had never even
expected but you have you must have some
I mean I think it's part and parcel of
your internal motor your drive like I
think a lot of people would have retired
and then just banked licensing checks
for you know just kick back you know but
you saw a greater opportunity and you
decided to like you know expand you know
exponentially based on those
opportunities yeah well I'd it just was
more out of out of fun yeah I just
thought oh this would be really cool
that I can now I can take McDonald's
marketing dollars and show people what
skateboarding is right um or I can help
to build more public skate parks through
through a charity and and people think
you know people understand and that's a
legitimate need in in society um I can
do a tour where we're not the sideshow
to the rock show we're actually front
and center skateboarding BMX motocross
you know things like that was the
catalyst for all that was definitely a
video game right but then you start like
incan you know a zillion endorsement
deals right and is that where the the
sort of sellout things oh I was already
you or I was already considered
long before that yeah as soon as as soon
as I got a Bagel Bites contract you know
that than I think that was that was the
moment where people were like all right
this is you know he's he's not on he's
not just having see a porn sponsors he's
he's doing stuff that's big corporate
evil entities very unpunished
this isolated pure movement I was always
trying to share what what good it did
for me with more people and we never
really had that opportunity if if when I
was 14 turning pro I got offered a
contract from Bagel Bites or from
McDonald's I would eat it up right I
wasn't fine you know what I mean yeah I
wasn't trying to keep it this this core
coveted sport but it seems like it was
that it's that thing like we're you know
a little indie band is cool and it has
its followers and that sure they do
their next album and it breaks huge and
then suddenly everybody turns out oh
yeah it's always a major of things but I
guess the funny thing is is that sure I
was the I was the guinea pig for that
sort of those types of endorsements but
now it's totally normal to be sponsored
by Toyota and be a skateboarder that
doesn't it doesn't even register on
anyone well the the the relationship
with the haters goes back very early
right because from the get-go you had a
very different style and yeah well I I
do some speaking engagements and this is
one of the points that I make is that I
was so set up for haters at an early age
that I sort of built this this shell
where when I was a kid I was so little
that I couldn't I couldn't propel myself
up and do aerials and stuff the way that
the pros were doing it because I didn't
have the weight I didn't have the bulk
and so I learned how to ollie into the
air and then grab my board and and the
the older generation said that was
cheating because if you ollie into here
then you can grab it anyway and I was
like exactly that's exactly what I'm
trying to do and so I got a lot of flack
for that and so it was very weird
I was in the small community already
considered an outcast because I skated
and then I was an outcast in that
outcast community uh-huh I was like
shunned because of my style and so that
just set me up to sort of prove myself
further
and so when then when the the era came
of being considered a sellout
I was already well-suited for hearing
that sort of negativity yeah a pariah
within a community yeah and so it was
like oh he's a so I was like please yeah
you guys used to hate my style you know
what I mean now my style is popular and
now I'm getting paid you know big money
because of it and now you don't like me
because of that let go please and then
so that set me up for the second
generation of haters which only set me
up for the third generation which is
social media mhm and so when people are
so crushed by the amount of negative
comments on social media it just passes
me by I was like these people used to
say this to my face do you even look at
it sure but but you know they're hiding
them behind anonymous right names and if
you look at what they're putting out
there they're just talking [ __ ] to
everyone yeah so it's like it's your
name is special but it's bizarre that
you are on the receiving end of that
kind of stuff because you're I mean
you're like widely beloved in your sport
you're one of the most popular you know
sports figures you know in our current
generation but you always find something
you know I can't say that that's that's
the the majority of the the comments I
get but it's always there right you know
or or people just want to they just want
to be cynical about what you're doing
and so like I said it's not that that's
that's the crux of what I what I get but
I'm I'm well prepared to handle it yeah
because of what I went through as a kid
how do you stay grounded you seem like
you have a healthy you know sense of
humility about everything that goes on
in your life like how do you maintain
that ah kids just you know like taking
care of kids and and five kids because
my wife and I we have six six oh well I
mean my oldest is 25 so it's not really
a kid but um but just you know the idea
that we we're gonna drive them to
whatever good like go take them surfing
or go to your friend's house and
and the kind of stuff we have to deal
with is just usual right parents all
like ridiculous requests do your dishes
you know it means so that stuff
definitely keeps you grounded because
kids just they don't they don't care if
you're famous do you have anything
that's a nuisance to them what do they
think about like who you are and what
you do and and and how has your
experience kind of informed or parenting
style um well they they like it in the
sense that it affords us certain
opportunities that most people don't get
most of all though all the boys skate so
they enjoy that I get to go to these
these skate parks you know fantastical
places and they get to skate and
sometimes they get to do it alone like
they'll get a skate park to themselves
or whatever like if we go to Zurich and
so they enjoy that aspect of it I think
that the only thing they don't enjoy is
that it requires so much of my time so I
have to travel constantly and do this I
don't have to but to maintain this
lifestyle you have to you know I've got
to figure out the balance of work and
and home and but they do they like it
they understand it for sure and your
oldest is he pro skaters pro skater yeah
he is well and so how does that work in
terms of like father-son you know
communication around here shadow he's
got a whole different style of skating
and he's got other interests too he's
kind of a Renaissance man he he he's in
a band that does pretty well he now he's
a part-time model so he's got other
things going on he wants to start a
coffee shop but I think it's just more I
led by example you know to show them
that yes this is fun yes it's amazing
you get paid for it but you have to work
at it
mm-hmm and and sometimes you got to jump
through the hoops in terms of doing
interviews and and being presentable I
mean you know it's not like you have to
force it but for sure
don't be addicted kids do you worry
about like that internal motor that you
have that allowed you to kind of you
know whether the hard times and you know
part of that is formative right there's
a lot of I think so yeah you know life
experience that comes out of and
well my oldest Riley he lived through
the lean times yeah so he understands
that he has a better appreciation for
the you know the cushiness of how we get
to live now but at the same time they're
all I want them to be self-sufficient I
want them to be self-motivated they
can't just rely on my success or my
finances for their their own see yeah
yeah yeah and now like currently like
how do you sort of think about or
partition your involvement in in
business you have your hands in a
million different things versus your
identity as an athlete like how does
that how does that even break down like
on a day-to-day basis ah well if you're
it I just try to I try to prioritize
mostly firstly family but I'd to make
sure that that there's a there's a very
high quality control going on with any
of my products and my companies that I'm
involved with and trying to skate as
much as I can trying to be interesting
like on social media things like that
and share fun things aren't just about
me I love the stuff that you share like
when people recognize you or they're not
sure that they recognize that's all I've
actually had a few people that that that
it was them that I'm speaking of uh-huh
and they'll comment like I just was
nervous I don't know I'm sorry like no
it gives me that gives me another story
right I think people are actually kind
of getting sick of that at this point no
but but every time it happens oh well
you know every fifth time it happens is
some unique interaction right I think
it's funny to share yeah so what is that
when you say like you know I try to
skate as much as possible well it like
you try you have like a training product
do you do I mean is it just skating or
do you do other stuff I I have well I
have my own ramp it's it's the ramp that
I built for our tour for a binman patch
a million-dollar ramp yeah it's in San
Diego and so it literally was skating
yesterday that's where my office is and
so summertime is a little different but
but generally my regular day would
consist of getting kids off to school
then going there and either
having meetings or taking phone calls
it's replying to emails something like
that maybe doing phone interviews or
whatnot and then trying to skate before
kids get out of school and then if after
that then I'm kind of at their disposal
whatever they want right they want to do
and then the travel is just and then
when I travel it's it's very much I'm
trying to fit everything in all once and
so traveling is kind of non-stop I guess
best example is like I'm going to Buenos
Aires in a couple months
I'm traveling quite a bit before them
but this is a perfect example in that
there's an event the day before that I'm
flying to Buenos Aires I'll be there for
16 hours doing this event doing speaking
thing doing a skate thing and then
flying right back into a fundraiser the
day I get back right but because I got
it all of those things were important to
do how do you figure out what to say yes
to and what to say no to it whatever I
feel like will have resonated best and
have the most impact or that I feel
strongly about but but definitely I've
learned to say no I think the probably
the best advantage of having all the
success is that it gives you the power
to say no things but all the stuff that
you get offered is cool you probably
want to do there's so much cool stuff
yeah it is it is very strange to be like
sorry I'm hanging out with this yeah
icon that you've revered your whole life
pretty much yeah like I got a thing
today like oh I really can't make the
movie premiere but I appreciate you yeah
this is literally like that was that was
an email I got today like I would love
to do it but next week is hectic and we
got the kids and can't just break out
for the night where do you think that
the the drive comes from is it just an
internal drive to be the best that you
can be be the most expressive does it
come from a sense of competing against
others like what's the genesis of the
whole thing I think it's always been
progression and wanting to challenge
myself I never felt I never wanted a
rest of my accolades I didn't really I
was never about like half of number one
because once I feel like if those are
your goals if your mindset is like I
want
or I want to be rich I want to be famous
if you get a taste of any of that you
lose your motivation mmm not that I had
this sort of perspective when I was a
kid but my goal was just to get better
my goal was just to get better at
skating and do better tricks and so even
if I won a contest I was out there the
next day is skating trying new stuff
uh-huh and that's never waned I mean
that's still how it is yes so that that
like devotion to incremental daily
progression spills over into business
life exactly yeah and and what and I
look for those challenges or I look for
voids in the market uh-huh where are
like oh this this could be a fun thing
to get into or to try to create a
movement here yeah and that's not the
sexy stuff everyone wants to see you on
the ramp or you know there's pictures
and videos and all that kind of stuff
but is the daily kind of like pressure
applied to that thing that you love or
whatever it is you're trying to move
forward yeah but I know that success
will come later or that that
appreciation will come later even if
it's not just a skating thing uh-huh
have you had what's the biggest failure
that you've had when we first started
having success as a skate brand we also
had a distribution arm and we were
carrying other skate brands and then we
started carrying like doing sort of
different clothing hookups a brand that
we created under that umbrella and then
we took in a designer and started doing
high-end denim around 2004 right when
that was a thing where people started
paying a lot of money for jeans but we
had this guy that was sort of right at
the right place right time in terms of
being really cool designs but we didn't
know we didn't know apparel yeah we
didn't especially denim and all of a
sudden it was eating all the profits
from the building I mean everything so
all the profits the other businesses
everything yeah and it got and my
partner wanted to keep it going I wanted
to keep getting bigger loans and and at
some point I was like we have to let
this go
this is
this is we're way in way over our head
and we basically sold the brand for what
we owed the banks hmm and so what yeah
well I mean that seems like a business
that's outside of your it was an end I
think we just we were we thought we were
invincible you know we are higher on
Owen's high on our own success and like
we can make anything work right and so
what do you take from that that like
helped you live ah that I can't get into
something just because I think it'll be
successful I have to really be
passionate and believe in it and
understand all the aspects of it I think
what would I what carried me through all
the success was was embracing all the
minutia and learning all the other stuff
about a business that maybe I didn't
care about as a kid and a lot of times
you know the the non-sexy stuff of
purchase orders and you know in paying
taxes and and all that stuff is just
things I didn't want to care about but
as I learn them as I embrace them that
helped me that helped me to be
successful right well in skating the
minutia is everything right being highly
attuned to the minutia and and figuring
out the tiniest shifts in your body
weight or whatever it is to make it work
and it's a very personal individual
endeavor and then you scale that up into
business and suddenly like I would
assume well as usually you have the
skater you have to be a control freak
about yourself right in a lot of ways
yeah but also air but but but I think
what would what contributed my success
was that I was I was willing to go
outside my comfort zone and so like I
learned techniques in skating that I
wasn't really interested in but I knew
it would help me be more well-rounded in
terms of competition or exhibitions in
terms of skating different terrain other
skate parks stuff like that and with
that mindset that helped me in business
because I was willing to get outside my
comfort zone and learn all these other
aspects of manufacturing mm-hmm we're in
a culture right now where suddenly it's
super cool to be an entrepreneur a small
business owner a start-up founder
everybody wants to be a startup founders
yeah so then you start up they won't
exit there
looking at the daily incremental
progression they're looking at the
destination yeah right so when you sort
of canvass young people or anybody for
that matter out there taking a stab at
business like what do you identify as
the common mistakes that like you see
immediately losing control of the brand
or the direction in in pursuit of fast
fast cash I think that a lot of people
they they see an in maybe an injection
of money and they think oh that's it
that's what they're celebrating yeah but
then they don't realize lay their
company they're giving away their
company and in no matter how much they
promise that it's going to be the same
thing it is never the same thing and
it's it's gonna be a whole new set of
employees in a whole new direction and
you have to maintain that control and
sometimes that requires buckling down
and and denying the money or the quick
money mm-hmm mm-hmm
when you look back on on your career
whether it's skating or business like
what are the fondest memories that that
stick out for you like what do you
remember most like when you're like oh
man remember that time how awesome that
was or how many I remember the leaner
times because they were so free and like
the early days of birdhouse was we're on
tour it was five of us in our delivery
van driving across the country skating
parking lots for a hundred people maybe
you know people and at a skate shop they
would just put up some wooden ramps and
they're in they're pregnant lot for us
to skate and we'd all share the same
hotel room and huh and even though that
all seems like a struggle it was it was
super fun because it was we just didn't
care we had nothing to lose yeah and and
that that was very liberating
I find that to be common amongst a lot
of different successful people when you
and they don't they don't remember oh
that it's not the IPO or standing up
podium I remember it back there were
plenty of great but like the fondest
like the ones that really like you know
hit you in the heart
it is those early days when life was
simple and there was nothing to lose and
it was just about your dreams you
but I can never downplay being on The
Simpsons yeah by far huh well that's
when you have just crossed over in the
biggest way yeah well I was in such it
yeah it was definitely a huge validation
um and and the fact that you know if
you're on The Simpsons as yourself
there's a cool factor that's undeniable
well now you have your skateboard in the
Smithsonian and like you skateboarded in
the White House or the office building
or so yeah no I did skate through the
White House actually where I got invited
there during a Father's Day celebration
when Obama was in office and I was
waiting it the nearby the Eisenhower
building is right next door
I was waiting there and I and I'd skated
through the hall and got a photo and I
thought that was super cool and then I
realized that once I got over the White
House I could just do the same thing
really quick before they told me no
uh-huh and I did did they tell you no
though they didn't but I knew not to
push it as Obama there did he see it he
didn't see me do it but I saw him right
after that you did uh-huh but the funny
thing is he actually one of the few
things he said to me was hey I'm really
sorry we're home any Rams for you to
skip ha ha yeah that would be cool if
there was a ramp out behind that had
just gotten one there just for you for
that day you know I think they wanted to
they wanted plausible deniability that
they didn't allow me to do that right
what do you think of this new sort of
motorized skateboard trend um I don't
know it's you know it's okay it's
Transportation sure yeah but I don't
really it's different yeah you're not
you're gonna kick flips on them yeah
they're cool though I'm sure you've
written you've ridden them yeah yeah
yeah in fact we're working on possible
line of that kind of thing that is more
in tune with real skateboards but does
have motors uh-huh it's not just long
boards right yeah that's cool so what is
uh what's exciting you now like what are
you into now that that's new you know in
this this you know continuation of
pushing the envelope
well I'd and brand has a lot of
potential we've been expanding that
globally and a lot in South America and
I feel like there's there's a lot more
we can do with that because our the
the whole basis of hawk clothing is is
cool clothes cool skate culture clothes
for kids and other than that probably
the one thing I'm really excited about
working on in the future is I have a
project with Mark Mothersbaugh where
we're gonna do with a Broadway play a
Broadway show
yeah in fact that that's that's coming
closer to reality than it ever has been
and that's super exciting to me because
I feel like we could do something really
unique in a Broadway setting right with
his music and my skating choreography
right so for people that are listening
who don't know Mark Mothersbaugh
legendary musician member of Devo and
now just an incredible composer for film
and television
yeah basically any of your favorite
movies are probably done before yeah
incredible musician yeah he's that's
exciting so what is that like what's the
storyline that we bought the rights to a
Nick Hornby book called slam which is
about a skater a teenage skater that
gets a girl pregnant it's about a teen
pregnancy it's about it's about them not
not just about him but about her as well
and we bought the rights to that and we
want to make it this sort of Broadway
production of this kid who has who is
that a crossroads of you know
responsibility and Annie still wants to
skate and I think it I think it's a
really good story and theme for four
kids today very cool yeah the whole
world of theater and Broadway has its
own rules it's very that's what I'm like
any other business yeah but I feel like
there I feel like it's with the success
of Book of Mormon right the success of
Hamilton we're seeing that you can do it
way different uh-huh and and be revered
yeah and I'm hoping that we can at least
get you know get some attention on that
so how far how far down the line are you
uh we're getting there yeah we're in the
middle of getting funding but it but
marks writing and we're designing sets
and things like that and are you gonna
be involved in are you gonna do
commentary on the Olympics or do you
ever gonna uh I I have definitely
planted that seed uh-huh we'll see yeah
cool I used to do all the X Games
commentary so I'm
you know I'm used to it beyond that I'm
working on a mobile game like a phone
skating game of course you are
well it's been a while I haven't done a
game and so how would this be well I
guess we're yeah we're in a new world of
what's possible and you're doing it with
mobile and everything like that yeah
yeah it's gonna it's not it's not with
Activision it's not thps there are hints
of it uh-huh what do you think we'll
wrap this up in a minute but what do you
what do you think gets misunderstood
about you or or that you wish people
kind of understood better about who you
are and what's important to you oh
that's a good question I think that I
think people have been focused on my
success maybe too much where they think
that that all I really ever cared about
was being rich or famous and that was
that was never my motivation because it
just didn't exist mm-hmm and even to
this day like it it's it's still
incidental to what I do and how much I
love skating but I feel like at least on
some level I've proven that over the
over recent years just with putting out
video parts and my age and things like
that and doing stuff that you know there
was no end game financially for any of
that yeah but I don't you know I think I
I come as I am you know what I mean I'm
not I'm not trying to present some other
persona and what you see is what you get
yeah I mean it's somebody who who has
you know followed your passion you know
who had a passion and has committed to
following it for as far back as you can
remember
it's very trite and kind of pithy to
tell people like you should follow your
passion most people are really so
disconnected from themselves that
they're not even really sure what that
passion is and so people say to you like
you know how do you find that or like if
I'm stuck in a cubicle and a job that I
hate you know how can I get a little bit
how can I get some of that to rub off on
me or like what should I do to try to
cultivate a little bit of that you know
sense of purposefulness and direction
I think it's more just really focusing
on something you love and making time
for it you know don't quit altogether
like if you want to if you want to take
that chance go for it I would definitely
I would I would support that as well but
I feel like you've got to carve it you
just gotta prioritize your time and you
got to carve out some time to do
something you really love mm-hmm it
sounds simple you know and but I know
it's hard well and I think people
overcomplicate it as well absolutely or
they feel like they're afraid to fail or
they feel like whatever it is they're
passionate about is silly
you know because maybe it's comic books
maybe it's something that yeah you know
and that's the thing is like giving
people permission and telling them it's
okay you could do something right that
was considered not cool mm-hmm and and
make it work and cultivate that inner
kid yeah good talking you man oh you
think yeah I appreciate you having on
you're easy to find on the Internet at
Tony Hawk everywhere everywhere at Tony
huh anything else coming up you want to
make people aware of ah good question um
I don't think so I'm you know pretty
pretty excited about all the stuff
coming out my plate is full for the most
part but in a good way and with kids
like my daughter is here actually she's
man in the camera her we are our
trade-off was that she gets to go to
restaurants really wanted to try up here
we'll get awesome man well I appreciate
you making the adventure up here yeah
thank you all right peace
by
[Music]